friend of the show George Kittle was in
WrestleMania with the Miz did I not call
that I'm friends with The Miz who's a
wrestler yeah oh The Miz is great man
great energy you guys a little bit
remind me of each other a little bit
actually I think that's a compliment
yeah it is a compliments he's good
people I love how big of a football fan
he is yeah you you both talked about a
little bit did I not say to him you guys
remind me of each other I wonder if he
knew that at the time and he just didn't
tell me I feel like he knew they've
they've probably known for a minute that
this was coming yeah
also I think I saw Hardy made an
appearance at some point too oh wow
maybe I'm wrong
he took him down right there he hit him
with one arm
there's certain jobs like hey I'm gonna
cut block you and I'm gonna hit you in
the knees and you know I I don't like
try to hurt anybody through it but like
just it's a part of the game yeah so
it's kind of weird but like I said it's
violence that's
um appreciated by everybody yeah I think
that's true so you have to does it
almost start to feel like wrestling then
at some point late in the league like or
like to an extent like there's there's a
lot like there's yeah I would say to an
extent like I would say there's a
handful of us out there who are treating
like wrestling to and like you know
having fun out there like that but uh
yeah I mean everyone's just everyone's
out there everyone wants like everyone's
goal is to win a Super I mean I hope
everyone's goal is to win a Super Bowl
like that's what my goal is and then
whatever comes with that but like I'm
not gonna go out of my head like you
know to inflict too much pain on
somebody but enough back in the day they
cared less about each other dude you
have like this wrestling type of vibe
about you right and people have said
that you're a wrestling fan I am if you
got into wrestling dude say after this
because that's what I I think I could
you start to become
some some guys they become some players
are some
some athletes they are also able to
become like a character in a way I feel
like you have like enough energy and
like
just like this kind of psycho Charisma I
would call it where you can also be like
a character yeah and it's like I do mean
it as a compliment but it's like so I
could almost see you doing wrestling one
day I would love to be in the ring at
some point really yeah so like I've been
I was in a match uh it was actually
right after I got drafted by the Niners
my buddy was doing a
um like a local it was like an hour away
from my for my house in Iowa he was
doing a show and it's actually uh Seth
Rollins WWE wrestler it's his wrestling
school in Davenport Iowa they put on a
show and I got in the ring right after I
got drafted and I did I got to pull a
stone cold stunner on somebody that was
exhilarating
um they were like I want to say there's
between
40 to 60 people in this little Arena I
mean and it was like it was like um
lives like just it was a building that
had didn't have uh like seating in it so
it's like just an open space like a Rec
Center sorry okay yeah they're a rec
center and there's literally like 40
people in there maybe and the pop
everybody's standing up and cheering
like that was one of the most
exhilarating feelings I've ever had in
my life so I literally from that moment
I was like I get why people wrestle it
is exhilarating when you get the crowd
to go oh my gosh
literally it's so much fun and so yeah
like I I can't wait till I have the
opportunity to get thrown through a
table or throw someone through a table I
can't wait
it's gonna be amazing it'd be really
really interesting do you think who who
from the NFL if you had to do tag
teaming if you had to have a tag team
partner from the NFL who would you pull
in no like
from like an athlete's standpoint like
just football player I'd pick Trent
Williams because he could he's one of
the yeah he's incredible and bring him
up and see if he can get him topless or
whatever just because we want to see
what who he is look up Trent Williams
back tattoo his nickname's a Silverback
oh really he's literally a gorilla oh
dang he yeah he's one of the guy one of
the Five Guys on my team that could kill
me with a punch wow wow oh yeah there it
is that's yeah I mean he's he's like
fully tatted now up top
oh that Jimmy's big huh yeah that's
young Trent Williams right there
but he's a stud but I would pick him now
if I was gonna pick someone who I think
would do like be a good WWE character
like a be a really good WWE wrestler
um
I think I mean Travis Kelsey like we'd
have a pretty fun uh like Titan Titan
Duo right there yeah the tightest ends I
could be called
ends that are tight
I don't know I mean I think you'll get a
new type of fan in the arena
you're not wrong I mean that's fine what
does that fan you I mean no sir oh okay
I love women's but I think that there is
a there's I think yeah you could get a
hold of my current profession I play in
Tights as it is so that's a good point
huh yeah I'm used to it but no like
there's some great characters in the NFL
who I think could make easy transitions
over I mean you saw Gronk did it like he
was at WrestleMania several years ago
but did he want it though Gronk I feel
like gets he he like he he gets put in
all like everything you know he's
selling shave lotion he's selling damn
Parkers or whatever I saw him on a um
somebody had him in a uh somebody was
doing Animals selling puppies or
whatever rescue animals or something so
I think you know he's almost done so
many things he does do a lot and I was
like did he want it though like I could
see you maybe becoming a member in it do
you feel like you would just do it as a
fun thing or do you feel like it could
be something you would actually
I think I would have really enjoyed
doing it right now like I will say like
after meetings like I've got the awesome
ARP too WWE is a fantastic company like
how they organize and run their stuff
like I've got I've gotten able to go
I've been able to go to like three
wrestlemanias oh wow and this literally
this last one like the way that it's ran
picked us up picked me and my dad and
one of my buddies up and my wife we got
to go backstage I gotta hang out the
Undertaker Stone Cold Steve Austin I got
to meet all these like people that I'm a
huge fan and then also wrestlers were
like when they're behind the scenes like
they're just they're normal like I'm an
NFL football player and people see me
like oh my gosh some like some like kids
are like oh my gosh it's George kidding
like that's how I was a kid like NFL
players are kind of superheroes that's
how kind of I am with wrestlers I'm like
it's so cool but as soon as you get them
off the stage they're just normal people
like the rest of us so just like just
have a conversation with them they're
all so cool like multiple guys are just
hanging out with my dad talking about
random stuff and like being able to have
that access is so much fun and so like
that's part of the other reason that
makes me really want to you know try it
and I think I would enjoy it but I was
sorry I was gonna say is like their
schedule like they're on the road
320 40 days they don't get enough credit
for their schedule oh my gosh like if
they're doing the Because you see
everyone you see Monday Night Raw you
see I think AWS on Wednesdays and then
you have Friday Night Smackdown and then
you have if there's a pay-per-view it's
on Saturdays or Sundays and then you
don't even count the ones that aren't on
TV there's like two uh non non-televised
shows um a week yeah there's like 80
there's a couple of other ones but like
no WWE puts them on they'll do like I
think they'll go like the Dubuque Iowa
and it won't be on TV but it'll be in
that air whatever Arena that is selling
tickets and they're just selling tickets
to put on the show so it's for local
shows and so it's a much smaller
production than like the live TV ones
but I've gone to a couple of those and
they're still really fun but it's just
like this they're they're in the ring
like I perform once a week they're in
the ring and we're at yes there's a
script to it but like you can't fake
falling off like getting thrown through
a table you can't fake jumping off the
top rope to the ground which is a 10
foot yeah it's like even if you went to
Phantom of the Opera but what if people
are beating the [__] out of each other
during it yeah like come on like it's
gonna hurt
so like that's why I just had I have
appreciation for wrestlers because it is
a grind one of my buddies like he's been
doing it since like he stopped playing
football with us so like let's just say
six years he has driven like he lives in
Davenport Iowa and he's driven probably
I mean he goes to Maryland to wrestle
Florida to wrestle California to wrestle
Arizona to wrestle Nashville like and he
just drives he doesn't fly that's
another thing they make him drive George
they get into a lot of these guys they
get they like they go to Avis they go to
the rental it is a you have to it is a
grind it is on you it is yes it's on you
to show up and be available to wrestle
like then you have like and like the
superstars in WWE like they probably fly
and they do stuff but like a lot of
people they just drive match the match
week to week year to year and not even
the superstars like I'm friends with The
Miz who's a wrestler yeah oh The Miz is
great man great energy you guys a little
bit remind me of each other a little bit
actually
um I think that's a compliment yeah it
is a compliment I like the mess he's um
he's good people I love how big of a
football fan he is I do he is he's a
he's a he's he's a good dude he um but
he would talk about how like you had to
like pay your I mean you would he's like
you get there there's fans that are
excited about the airport but then you
just you have to go get your rental car
you have to [__] get in you have to
drive two and a half hours then you have
to go uh run through the script in the
ring it's like I'm like damn it's a lot
that's a lot and then you have to
perform yeah think about like think
about like you have to put oil on your
body
like you like us like you'd have to wet
your hair back and like so it doesn't
get all in your face and then some of
those guys are out there performing like
not every match is like super long but
like there are guys that go out there
and do like the 25 minute matches like
that's a lot of cardio oh yeah oh that's
like two more yeah yeah like what an
orange theory but people are beating the
[__] out of each other in it with chairs
dude it's nuts just like the time that
it like the time and then like the
physicalness and like they don't get
time to rehab and like do all that stuff
they don't have access to all that stuff
like I have a facility I get to go to
every day yeah they're at the hotel pool
they're at the hotel hot tub hopefully
it has a bathtub so I can take a hot
bath tonight to warm up my legs yeah
it's crazy you probably go to the yeah
you go to like the ice machine you open
it up and uh you know half of The Hardy
Boys are there or whatever you're like
damn this is crazy yes I think it's a
tough it's a really really tough gig I
just think there's a lot of things that
are a little bit behind the scenes of a
lot of performances yeah that you just
see the the show yeah and you don't see
like a lot of the other stuff that has
to go on no um dude I I like I always
enjoy whenever I'm backstage and you can
like catch someone like a like a tag
team with the other Tag Team fake going
through the match it's so cool to see
that stuff it's just it's really
interesting because I'm like wow like
there's a lot of intricacies to this and
like there's a because there's always a
build up to the match and then like you
just for them to know it because it's
not memorized but like they're out there
trusting each other that the guy's gonna
do what they expect them to do yeah it's
crazy and if you have to memorize
something you're dumb it's [__] hard
oh my gosh it has to be so difficult oh
dude I was you know I wouldn't say I'm
yeah I'm like kind of
you know but I've definitely been dumb
and had to memorize [__] and not done it
it just it couldn't there's like there
are some things that are just hard and
it is what it is
hope you enjoyed that video and you can
watch another and you can watch this one
you can watch this one different options
different choices some guy just brings
you one option not this guy two options
watch one this one or this one